we've been so lucky on numberphile of
having Ron Graham
talking about Graham's number it was
amazing that we could do that and
Graham's number was a famous number that
was the largest number at that time it
was the largest number I'd ever been
used in our proper mathematical proof
and then we got one Graham to talk about
is he fantastic 12 is not enough it
turns out and this other slightly bigger
number but before Vaughn Graham the
number the largest number that had been
used in a proper mathematical proof was
a different number called skews number
asked us number it's a word that I've
only ever seen missing downs I'm not
quite sure but it's a large number I'll
show you what that number is 10 to power
10 to power 10 to power 34 now this is
going to be a large number this is a
number that's something like trillions
of trillions of trillions digits long
massive mean Google a Google is 100
digits long misses trillions and
trillions and trillions of digits long
right so this is huge so where did this
number come from
so this number was like the Graham's
number of its time such a huge number I
mean even Isaac Asimov wrote about this
number so I see Asimov I've taken this
from brady this is not minus Brady's
book I took it off his shelf Isaac a
some of the science fiction author wrote
about this number as well read an
article about it and the kind of number
finally kind of what if there was a
number far in the 1970s we all would
have had Isaac Asimov on talking about
skewers number which would have been
amazing a 1970s numberphile would have
been also people had massive ties and
sideburns and would be constantly
smoking I want to see how compared to
Graham's number this is tiny but at that
time this come we're talking this is
before their computers and Thanksgiving
this is a massively not large number
what was the problem
they were solving with this number
do with primes and counting primes so
the classic problem which goes way back
to how many Prime's are there let's say
less than a given number right so this
goes back to Gauss I've done I've talked
about this before the prime number
theorem which is you know fantastic
stuff
Prime's less than X which we write as PI
of X so this is not pi this is PI as in
paper prime rather than P for perimeter
which i think is what that may be what
PI comes from so if we do PI of 10 how
many Prime's are there less than 10 2 &
3 & 5 & 7 tell me if I'm wrong all right
so there's 4 [ __ ] before and if we did
how many Prime's less than 100 I know
this this is this 25 less than 100 and
if I did how many Prime's are there less
than a billion then less than a billion
that number is 50 million eight hundred
and forty seven thousand five hundred
and thirty-four Prime's
less than that now girls this I'm
incredible when he was 15 years old and
you think he'd have better things to do
like hanging around the shops or
something but when he was 15 years old
he came up with a formula to approximate
what this value might be his formula
originally was this number is roundabout
x over the log of X that's the natural
log of X you might write that as Ln of X
some of you may have seen that so this
would have been like this so this is an
approximation register you know it's a
bit skew is not quite right they did
caught with a better approximation I
want to show you the better
approximation it's do Ashley who came up
with this and his approximation that the
prime counting function is something
called they will call it Li of X it's
called the logarithmic integral it's a
function some of you will not be
familiar with what I'm going to do which
is fine it's just a folks you just say
this
a clever maths formula for this if you
are familiar with what I'm doing then
you'll understand what this is and this
is defined as the integral between 2 and
X of 1 over the natural log of T DT but
yes a formula so there's a formula for
it so let's apply it let's see what it
does let's do the same numbers let's do
10 so I change that to a 10 okay if I do
it for 10 I think the number you get is
5 it's not bad okay so it's not right
it's not correct but it's say it's not
bad far even it's 4 if you do it for 100
you get 29 it was actually 25 so you're
for office - pretty good actually he's
pretty accurate and if we do it for the
big number it gets more accurate the
number the bigger the numbers are so
let's do it for a billion here for a
billion how close are we going to get to
the true value which was 50 million
eight hundred forty seven thousand five
hundred thirty four you get 50 million
eight hundred and forty nine thousand
two hundred and thirty-four is so close
considering how big these numbers are
that is one thousand seven hundred off
which is not much when you're talking
about these size of numbers and so this
is a really quite accurate it's really
good but it does appear and you can see
there that's this estimation always
seems to be bigger
so always overestimating so this bigger
and Gauss had to look at this as well he
said Gauss thought it's always seems to
be pick and he checked it - he checked
it up to like three million and it was
always bigger so people thought your
prime counting function was always going
to be less than this this estimation
thing we're doing this is what they
thought okay that'd be great until until
little wood that's another map Natisha
Cambridge mathematician at the beginning
of the 20th century with over a hundred
years ago 1914 little word realized
that it's not always true that your
logarithmic integral approximation
sometimes isn't bigger that in the
quality sign flips it flips and in fact
it's just that infinitely many times
throughout the numbers but he couldn't
tell you the first time it flipped it
must be something big but he couldn't
tell you the first time he did it
so this matter is curious found a
approximation or a bound for when the
first time this inequality finally flips
this number is his bound he said he's
saying it must be less than this it
flips and it flips at a value less than
that number doesn't know what it is yet
but I mean he knows it's less than that
it could be a lot it could be a lot less
exactly it could be a lot less than that
but he knows it's not bigger than that
so the first time it flips now we've
improved this estimate since then we now
think that it might flip somewhere
around a score a one point three nine
eight times ten to the power 316 and
actually leave me think this is actually
quite a good estimate for screws number
the first time this flips so we're
talking a number that is a Google Google
Google big number we don't know exactly
where that flip is we still haven't
found where that flip is we're pretty
short is somewhere around that area
though we're pretty confident of that we
have found a run of integers where the
inner quality is the other way around
there is a run of integers between these
numbers 1.5 3 times 10 to the 1165 and
1.65 times 10 to the power 1165 there is
a run of consecutive integers where this
inequality is the other way round by
which I mean your prime counting for
action is greater than the estimate this
is a example of thinking that because a
pattern holds for a very long time it's
going to hold forever and it turns out
no so this is a pattern that holds which
we think for numbers going bigger and
bigger and bigger until they're getting
huge sizes of goulds of googles of
googles and it appears that this
inequality holds and then it flips all
numberphile videos are supported by msri
but today's episode was also brought to
you by lynda.com Linda has a great range
of video courses and tutorials something
you'd never have gotten in the 1970s
almost anything you want to learn Linda
has you covered I was going through a
few things just yesterday and stumbled
over this really cool course about
recording sound from drum kits it's
really fascinating and something I could
have used last week to be honest Linda
have also got all sorts of great stuff
covering photography video creation
business software tips you name it
there's over 3000 video courses and a
hundred thousand tutorials in the
catalog you can sign up now for a free
10-day trial that's unlimited access to
all of them by going to lynda.com slash
numberphile or clicking on the link in
the video description
that's l-y NDA comm slash numberphile
give it a try and they'll know you came
from here on this channel
our thanks to Linda for supporting
numberphile